have you ever met quintuplets like  somebody with quintuplets five five  babies born in one birth i mean what are  we kittens that's crazy man what about  the octo mom how'd she do it i know  should i see that picture of her belly  the octomom it looks like she swallowed  a legitimate boulder from colorado yeah  like huge yeah yeah like that  like look at a rip she is how is her  body not tearing in half  you know also how are there eight kids  just flopping around in there no like  what's going on in there man what is  going on in there in every single one  every single so many babies that's not  even that's what three  octa-mom's doing porn  no stop it  she looks like tt jerry there octomom  home alone  wait what what  what do you go you just you porn pornhub  eight street latinas what do you do